[Applause]
yeah thank you very much so i'm i'm a
lawyer uh happy to be here um are there
any lawyers in the room
excellent what good enough
why why
ah okay
but but you bounce back
very good
um so i
as alexander said i um
i work in the legal tech space
broadly speaking um
i had a traditional career as well
for six years
and then i founded the illegal tax
product
which did not work out but i remained in
trench in that space and i also
i did reach out to um
does the mic work yes
i did reach out to the
to the pi data community in berlin
and that's eventually how we
how we met which is
quite odd that being in frankfurt it
took the detour of me going to berlin
to link with the community and then meet
people from manheim to start working
with them but but i think that's how the
well works and i think that's a good
good example
um
so i will talk to you about um nlp
in
in a legal context so what's nlp natural
language processing i think for you
people i don't need to
explain that for lawyers
nlp could be something completely
different
they would probably think it's it's npl
which is non-performing loans
so
so nlp in a legal context so what does
it mean
i think for for the purpose of this talk
which is also time box
we can forget about
robo lawyers and robo judges
um of course the
um
the desire for
things like that has been large i think
people if people can get rid of lawyers
they they will be quite open-minded um
about the opportunity and i think that's
so that's why these topics are are sexy
to a certain extent they also
[Music]
link to what larissa talked about right
to ethical questions in terms of if
suddenly
a lawyer or especially a judge or
or an administrative agency
is replaced by a machine
there are a lot of implications
in in space so but
for my part and for the people that i
talk to i can safely say
we're not there yet
and the more realistic challenges that
that are suitable for for nlp in the
illegal context are
the ones i've listed there which are
compliance due diligence and discovery
compliance is a large topic in law
probably the one that you are
that you are familiar with if you work
in a company
it's
being
compliant with applicable laws and
regulations and that can mean a lot of
things it can be anti-money laundering
it can be
data protection rules
it can be
[Music]
domain-specific or industry-specific
rules like health regulations
um
all of these things
it does involve usually does involve a
large larger amount of data
legal problems often involve very small
amounts of data if you have a question
about your lease contract you approach
your lawyer with one lease contract
if your lawyer would try to be a data
scientist and say well i'll build a
model with lease contracts he might find
six
now you tell me whether that is a
suitable model to build
to build something that can say your
lease contract is valid or not valid or
there are these these problems in your
lease contract so compliance is one one
of the areas where a lot of people feel
um
some some things can work another one is
due diligence
if you're not fully familiar with the
term that's that's the thing you do
to check whether the thing that you buy
is what you want to buy um and it is
most relevant in the context of buying
companies because the company right you
cannot look at it if you buy zmans
you're not going to to the siemens
building you look at it you think it's
okay you buy it but rather you have to
check everything that siemens does on
the planet
and part of the due diligence is always
legal due diligence that means you go
through
the documents and you check
you check
you check are there any legal problems
are there any legal issues in there so
that that could be what translates to
you as anomaly detection for example or
the extraction of relevant data
it could involve just trying to figure
out what are the kinds of documents that
we are working with what are maybe
jurisdictions that we're working because
for lawyers the jurisdiction of the
document can be very relevant
because
you have to choose which lawyer you want
to work with right if you put a german
lawyer on an italian law problem
you're not spending your money wisely
probably you will also simply refuse and
say that's not that's not my
jurisdiction
um so that can be quite interesting and
and to make that maybe a little bit more
to elaborate on that
what used to happen
in these cases was that
people would build physical data rooms
i.e the companies would start putting
paper into files
and they would put it in a room
somewhere
and the lawyers would go there by train
or by plane live in a hotel close by
and every day at some point someone
would open the room the lawyers would go
in and would
start reading the documents taking
physical notes and then they were not
allowed to take the files with them
so they had to read them they had to
understand what's in there they had to
take notes sometimes they were not
allowed to take notes and then it would
go back and then there would be 40
lawyers or so
or 50 depending on on how large that
exercise was so
so already one one one major evolution
was digital data rooms
um for lawyers it was a little bit
disappointing because that meant there
were no more trips right
in the past due diligence was at least
well we're going to rome or we're going
to rio de janeiro now it's well we have
rio de janeiro documents but you're
sitting at home or in the firm
looking at it and looking at a computer
screen but it did save a lot of money
already
and now of course the idea is well if we
have that in a data room
why are we not doing something with data
science or why
can we can we start analyzing these
documents using using modern
technologies
such as natural language processing
discovery is what you do in court cases
where if you soothe siemens
and you're not sure you have all the
evidence
if your case is at a certain level
siemens might be
obligated or ordered by the court to
provide you with the document
and that's
especially it's especially common in the
us and that's also why the u.s
tools are the most advanced because what
the u.s lawyers came up with in terms of
well we have to show you documents we
also it's they have to show all the
relevant documents so if someone's suing
you for example for putting poison in
the water
technically once the judge orders them
to deliver all the relevant documents
you have to send them the documents
where the ceo says put that poison in
the water i don't care who dies
of course you don't want to give that
paper to the other side but you also
don't want to make yourself criminally
liable for for withholding the paper
from the court so what they started
doing was that they were sending
so much paper hoping that people would
not find the one piece of relevant
information
so i'm guessing if i was asking you what
we what would be your dream scenario to
do some training would be someone
taking one relevant piece and putting it
in as large a pile of possibly not
relevant pieces
so that's why why discovery is one of
the parts where these tools are
being used
the the other aspect is
can we and what we're desperately trying
to do is can we find other areas where
we have a lot of documents coming in
that are kind of of legal nature
so we can use similar techniques or
start
training or trying to figure out what
works and what what doesn't
um so
you see a lot of these
consumer league attacks
trying to use these techniques so for
example
your flight rides
your
your upman
thing so fire sharing
whatever whatever area you have where a
lot of consumers are being sued or are
being sent papers and you as a provider
could say well give me all of your
papers and i will try to figure out how
to answer your question
the problem there is
if you offer that service but you don't
have the tool to do it yet you need to
do it yourself and that's why not
everyone is is doing it
um
something that's very relevant for
lawyers is kind of the evolution that
has happened in that space so
there were waves of
we can replace lawyers with technology
already
the old one was called rex informatic
information technology and law
and
that was there the approach was the old
one
so can we
kind of look into the heads of the
lawyers and try to
rule based or decision tree based or
whatever it is but but but kind of
reproduce the way a lawyer say things
find the smartest lawyer understand how
he works and just build something that
works the same way
it didn't work i think the more
prominent example of that not working is
ibm watson
um ib but ibm watson actually was
something that that was branching out
into the legal world where a lot of
lawyers work with ibm on trying to
figure out how ibm watson could do legal
work um in my firm
they cooperated with ibm on that and i
think it was
probably
five to six years ago
where they showed us a presentation of
ibm watson and said this thing is now as
smart as a legal trainee
so you'll be gone by
in about two to three years right when
this thing finishes university so to
speak
um fortunately it
it did not develop that way but this is
but this is where where we were in the
past um another example i think that
that
that illustrates well is google
translator
which was kind of um
kind of put in the shadows by dl
and the interesting bit about dbl and
using new technology is dl as far as i
know started as a translation tool
but giving context where you could start
typing in sentences and it would
translate the full sentence rather than
giving you piece by piece words
um and what they did
is they took the internet
and what was the
the translation assistant that they use
does anyone know
who did their work for them
yes from
from which institution do you know
the european union so essentially when
you when you use that tool and you
started typing in it would always show
you where it got its ideas from and the
top five hits usually would be
translations within the european union
because
we probably wasted a lot of money on
that but but we did create a lot of data
in terms of translating things into 28
languages or more
and
but but you were right
those were a lot of legal texts
which funnily enough means that when we
lawyers use dl
it's quite accurate because it has it
has that lingo of legal documents and
this this european union commission
speech it does understand that very well
so
so
you you see
how
that technology is now more suitable
to do legal work because when you do
legal work the first thing you need to
do is you need to understand
language so one of the major barriers
has dropped now
the other one however is that a lot of
this data structure stuff that you have
to do to do the work that you do is is
even more complicated in the legal world
so you you
building all of that identifying where's
our data coming from is it coming from
crms is it coming from erps i.e what are
people doing in the company that would
be your anti-money laundering monitor
stuff is it is it external sources such
as data roofs or is it operations is it
is it companies is it factories um are
there apis usually there are no apis
so all of that makes it makes it super
difficult um and
what happens a lot is that people are
now trying to work on the infrastructure
rather than the advanced models because
the models are usually there
but the infrastructure to get the data
to the model is not there and there's
as far as i know there's not a lot of
experimentation going on because we we
have very limited data sets and if
someone has a data set they're not
making it open source they're not
publishing it they're keeping it to
themselves
so whoever whoever would would be
willing to work on that
i think every every open source minded
lawyer would be
very grateful
so
so what happens now and
i talked to a couple of people over the
the last couple of days in
in anticipation of this talk
there is kind of a toolkit approach in
the legal space so
you would have to look at your if you're
for example a company that wants to do
more legal work with tech
um or a law firm you have to look at
your
your structures right where where are
gaps
are we digital at all or are we still
using fax machines are the partners
still putting stuff on paper and then
it's an image scan
or are we actually digital
um
and other things
what are what are the tools that we're
using how are we pushing data through
the firm or through through a company um
so a lot of the homework is do we have a
data infrastructure or do we not have it
um what are workflows um what does you
know how and the skills so you can
imagine lawyers
not the most advanced tech people on
the planet
we were skeptical about email until very
very recently
we are moving off of fax machines
slowly but surely
we have our own secure mailing system
which cost as much as it costs to build
google in the first place
and it didn't work when when we started
out so there was a lot of frustration
within the legal community about that
the usability is a bit problematic it
requires you to buy a card reader
to get a card issued by the notary
chamber to pay 50 euros a year for that
and then to get into your mailbox you
have to put that card into the card
reader you have to know your pin you
have to download a client to to to work
with the card reader i when i first
started that i i told a friend i think i
can now also launch nuclear weapons
because that system cannot be more
complicated than
than this but
that's the fun part when you do that you
feel very important because you have
this card reader you plug it in and plug
the card you start the client server it
does some java things um you have to i
think start a lot of things that are not
necessarily secure but but your your
mailbox is secure
so so that's something where lawyers
have a lot of problems um now we've
learned working with that now we have to
start understanding sharepoint and
things like that so so it's really
difficult for us
and then you look at you look at the
toolkits that you have in the legal
space which i think can be interesting
in terms of linking up the different
communities um there's some legal
operations stuff there's some
outsourcing stuff so do you still need
to use lawyers for all of that work
probably not
um
you have workflow and automation tools
so you start linking up things like
contract generation right rather than
teaching
a model how to write a contract
in most of the cases the contracts you
can start building a contract in a
modular way and use more simple tools
that essentially are then also a little
bit more decision tree wise to build to
build solutions that ask people
questions and then the contract comes
out and that's more an expert system
approach but at some point then the
question is
do you want to build your own legal nlp
or are you using one the most prominent
one being hera and they are they're a
good example they're from the united
states i think they're trained a lot on
on
the data that is available in the united
states and they are delivering
decent results
um
and but they are the only ones i think
who are delivering actually these decent
results um and in the german space of
course you have the problem of
retraining that software to understand
german language legal documents so i
hope that gives you a little bit of an
understanding of what's happening
in that
space if
if you are interested in that i would be
happy to talk to you um about it because
i think it's it's really necessary um to
push that forward
uh if if you want if in the end you want
a legal
nlp lawyer
instead of your physical one
okay thank you very much
[Applause]